for more than 30 years defence has been
a low priority for germany a military
that was once one of the largest in nato
has shrunk to a third of its former self
but to the german chancellor russia's
actions in ukraine have changed
everything we will invest two percent of
our gdp in defence every year from now
on president putin should not
underestimate our determination to
defend every square meter of our
alliance's territory together with our
allies
the conservative leader of the
opposition believes the military reality
in ukraine now needs to be seen as
another part of vladimir putin's
political project
the threat of a war in ukraine is not
the only threat that we are seeing along
with tanks putin has also been rolling
out waves of propaganda throughout
europe easy to spread in the age of
digitalization and social media doing
damage with great efficiency damage
that's threatening the stability of our
society from the inside by strengthening
the military olaf shots will be doing
what angela merkel could not
simultaneously fulfilling a commitment
to nato and effectively ripping up the
post-cold war strategic playbook and
starting again
but not with the intent to use the army
for aggressive actions
instead to reassure both friends and
allies
it's not just on the military side that
shots is reversing previous miracle
policy
for many years germany has been
increasingly reliant on russian natural
gas imports
now shots wants to reduce that by
refusing to certify the controversial
nordstream 2 gas pipeline and promising
to buy liquid natural gas from
non-russian sources and to fast track
building the infrastructure it will need
in wider society many feel the same
sense of outrage expressed by olaf shots
it's unacceptable that such a man throws
europe into crisis again that is totally
unacceptable we can't support that
there is little doubt what many in this
country make of what president putin and
his forces have been doing in ukraine
the question is what he will make of
what's being done about it in germany
dominick kane al jazeera berlin